we just want to know if there's anything
we can pray for for you wow and as soon
as he said that it was a really
interesting thing her whole countenance
really changed like she she switched off
from the process performance to this is
me she became yeah the the mother and
the person you know the mother of her
children she started talking to us
like immediately just flipped and she
said actually
yes i believe in prayer i believe in god
and i pray too
have you ever been in a situation where
you feel completely hopeless there is
something that you can do
find out on this episode of led live
[Music]
light exposing darkness
hey everybody welcome to led live today
is going to be a sensitive topic if you
missed last week's topic on human
trafficking you're going to want to
click and watch that video because we're
going to continue that conversation and
i wasn't part of that conversation but
i'll tell you what i heard little parts
and bits of it and man
if there's something that boils my blood
it's human trafficking so thank you guys
for joining up on the show i want to
also introduce to you
micah has probably never officially been
seen on this channel before but he's
always first time first time he's always
been behind the scenes he he is our
cinematographer that makes us look
really good and uh welcome on the show
his brother levi also is joining us
today
i'm here from worlds okay moral support
levi thank you for coming and alex you
guys are both from michigan
yep
sort of you're all over the board yeah
yeah
i'm from there he's i just recently
moved there very nice very nice okay
well i'm excited to get into this topic
i know that this is probably difficult
for some people to talk about yeah um
but uh i think it's necessary we need to
have some information on this and i
think it's going to be a neat
story that you're going to tell today
that's really going to help us
apply this to something greater because
a lot of times i feel overwhelmed in
what i'm doing right and so just to hear
about how you can actually be effective
one person is pretty and neat so
and one of the things is i think that
through this experience god try to
broaden it beyond just how do we affect
something that is like human trafficking
but anything that could be considered
hopeless anything any battle that is
bigger than ourselves like what are the
principles by which you kind of go forth
and have a a level of success that you
could not have otherwise amen so for our
viewers alex give me a little bit of a
backstory
maybe they didn't watch the first one i
suggest you guys should go back and
watch that because that'll give you the
whole backstory of where he got into
this work but um real quick you you you
got involved in human trafficking and
you're now ending up in brazil how did
you get there right so i never actually
trafficked humans i got involved in
counter-human trafficking perfect i
always have to clarify that because
everybody will say that too that's
actually really good um
so like i caught myself multiple times
even presenting yeah you know i'm
involved in human trafficking people
like really i was like no actually
that's not what i meant yes um
so i i was i was living in kenya and uh
we went to south sudan to to help a
pastor friend of of my friends and we
were building him a house i met an
eight-year-old girl who was married off
by her mom to a year old man uh upset
beyond belief
couldn't figure out
how to get her out of that situation
came back to the states began
frantically searching for i don't want
to be in a situation like that again so
what do i do and then you know kind of
just researching the issue you start
googling things and all of a sudden more
stuff comes up than than you were
planning on and so i kind of it opened
up my view i started going to
conferences started reading books
started watching documentaries and all
of a sudden it was like this is not a
sudanese problem it's not a third world
problem this is a world problem and this
is not a human trafficking issue this is
a slavery issue right human trafficking
is just kind of like this tip of the
iceberg as i call it of of a slave
a
problem that has existed as i call it
the world's oldest business and you know
um so i got involved with organizations
became fairly prominent and well-known
our organization did and i was one of
the the main guys there from the
beginning
um and so we had a lot of exposure to
things and you know things that were
encouraging and things were that were
quite discouraging um
you know and and you know i just
my entire experience during this time
was purely from working with a group of
people and here
you know i was leading up to this
experience in brazil and this was where
god was just kind of taking all that
away where i no longer had that
background and and even my experience
was very different because i was no
longer in the context that i knew right
so you're in brazil because brazil has
like uh huge sporting events and things
like that that draw yeah because i've
heard that that that is really a big
draw for the human traffickers yeah so i
mean we had worked during large events
in the united states and that kind of
was what prompted it it was it was
actually my experience in 2013 in new
orleans during the super bowl that kind
of
made me see like
we had been exposed to other events as
well this was kind of one of the major
ones we went as a big team and we were
working around the clock and we were up
to late nights and it was just the
atmosphere was just so oppressive that i
was kind of like
man i
i need to i need to see if there's
something that we can do for this even
larger event that's coming up next year
and how aware are people like during
those events that know that that goes on
i'll i'll be
i'll be honest with you my guess my best
guess and what i think a lot of people
would say is pretty pretty ignorant like
it just most people just don't know that
that actually was what happens and so it
is fairly underground um and but i i can
also say that you know every event
probably
caters to a slightly different crowd in
a slightly different way and so there's
there's certain events that are probably
might maybe more overt like a like a
rock or rap concert would be very
different crowd than like a sporting
event right where you go with your
family and stuff like that you're not
you're not looking for that type of
thing but if it's like you know like
a mature concert where they're gonna
already be talking about sex and things
like that which is common within music
industry then you can have a little bit
more openness about that kinds of things
so yeah wow that's crazy and so
obviously going to brazil during the
world cup or something you know is why
you ended up filming there so i wanted
to be there before it so i ended up so
the world cup was starting in june
of 2014 and i ended up leaving in
november of 2013.
so the the
um the super bowl was also in 2013 i i
always forget when the super bowl was
february march or something like that
and so after that i'd spent a few months
trying to figure out make some
connections adventists and
non-adventists as to you know people
here that maybe want to go over there or
people there they're already working
just trying to say like hey guys let's
get a group together and let's do
something and then once i got there that
all just disappeared so um yeah i was
kind of left with myself i was by myself
yeah yeah so i couldn't convince anybody
to go with me and you don't speak the
language no not really no no i probably
knew like two or three words nice yeah
yeah so where the bathroom is oh
actually not not even that one not even
that one
um
so
but but yeah it was just
it was something that was pretty
eye-opening wow so wow so what did you
do in that situation i mean how could
you even be effective with one person
well that's the question that's the
question that's the thing that i i guess
i struggled with and kind of what put me
in in a place of frustration and that
eventually that place of frustration and
desperation is what what allowed god to
finally work
and so
it looks impossible yeah that's that's
when he does his best work right you're
backed up against the
the red sea nowhere to go egyptian army
coming at you and it's like asking
questions like why did you bring me here
yeah yeah so that definitely was a
question like i told everybody that i
was coming here to do something and here
i am a month in and i don't even know
what i'm supposed to do wow and what am
i going to do walk back home with my
tail between my legs right and so it's
kind of like no i'm staying and i don't
know what i'm what i'm going to do but
but you're going to have to show me
you're going to have to show me soon
well yeah wow well i'm i'm excited to
hear about how what happened to this
yeah this event the the dark part it was
kind of in the last episode so now we're
going to focus on kind of like what is
that that you know
through the midst of challenges like how
does how does god shine a light into our
life kind of thing and so um
i i ended up in in brazil god proved to
me that that he wanted to strip away
kind of all my dependencies on
not just necessarily my experience but
kind of like on
on my
um
professional
skills in in this regard like you think
you know a lot about a subject or a lot
about an issue and then you kind of come
with this you know god trying to take
all that back my dependency on people
and institutions and god says listen
there's a moment in time where where
that's not going to be there that's
going to fail you
and you need to learn how to have
trust in me and also i think primarily
to learn that this is
any big issue or any issue at all really
has a spiritual component and and the
spiritual component component is
obviously most often just overlooked
and and how do we look through the lens
of the great controversy beyond just a
theoretical but how do we actually how
does it manifest itself in our life how
do we live actively in it right so
practically yeah so it needs to be more
than just like a world view or yeah it
needs to be like okay i know this is
happening but how do i function within
that
and so you know it kind of i made a deal
with god okay i get it that i'm supposed
to pray and i knew that that was the
least favorite thing of mine to do
like i wanted to rescue i wanted to
build something i wanted to do something
i just want to do something with my
hands i'm a man right i want to see
results
you know
i don't want to involve myself in
something ethereal like you know on my
knees and praying but i also had a very
limited idea of what prayer was and so
through this kind of idea of walking
around these slums for five hours and
praying i was kind of like you know what
god just wants me to be present
god wants me to be present and in tune
in a conversation with him so that he
could reveal to me places that are in
trouble people that are in trouble and
when i'm looking for that when i make
myself available all of a sudden the
opportunities present themselves i don't
have to go searching for them i just
have to be available for when they
happen
and so i said all right well let's let's
continue
and you know i made the deal with god
take me to the 12 cities that are all
hosting these these
um
the world cup
and you know i'll pray for the cities
i'll pray for the stadiums and i was
like i i also want to know because i
need i think that i should be continuing
to enter the slums
so like i already knew that i was going
to pray for the cities but i kind of
wanted some direction as to like i
wanted to pray in the slums i mean
that's where i started like i ended up
walking into a slum accidentally where i
was told not to by
where i was you know i was kind of like
outside of one but the five hours ended
up going all over the place and and so i
knew that that i wanted to walk into
slums but everyone was telling me don't
do it i need confirmation
when you mean slums this is the favelas
favelas yeah yeah which is which is
interesting i've been to brazil a number
of times and and it's funny because they
always say the americans they come down
there and they all want to go in there
and they're like why yeah why are you
guys so fascinated with this because
they go on for miles and miles and
they're these endless houses built on
houses and
i've always heard that's where all the
crime
people live and yeah i mean they have
their own culture in their everything
and some are are known or pretty
notorious and so they've been there some
of that have been featured in
documentaries and even in movies and and
a number of different things and so you
know there's there's kind of like this
this idea you know romanticization that
that can appeal to the foreign mind and
going to favelas but everybody there was
saying don't be stupid like don't go
into a belly you'll stand out like a
sore thumb like they all know each other
and some might be fine some aren't
necessarily dangerous they're just
impoverished but certain ones like
you're really risking it they're trying
to hide something yeah so if you go to a
poor one yeah maybe they'll look at you
maybe they'll rob you but if you go to a
dangerous one like it could be it could
end up a whole lot worse you get enough
kidnapped ransomed you know
killed but it doesn't matter like it
just the the no one would find out
nobody would come looking for you right
and so it's a great place to disappear
and and so this is the recommendation
was don't go
and then the final thing was you know i
had worked with counter trafficking but
i wasn't in a position where i felt like
i could do or be effective in that
regard so i was like lord if you still
want me to at least reach out to
prostitutes in a similar way that that
the groups that i worked with in atlanta
did you have to reveal it to me that you
want me to talk to them and then you
have to like
make it clear that that there's going to
be groups of people in the cities where
i go that i can teach them how to do it
that they can do as a church group
you know so so send me people you're
going to have to like reveal at first
that i should do it and you're going to
have to then
in some way prepare
14. give me the team that that that are
committed and that are like sincere
because you know there's people who are
just like i just want to be part of a
cool thing like i don't want those
people
and so not that i need to tell god that
he probably knew that a whole lot better
than me but you know i i
i knew that i was just gonna walk and
pray so i was like all right and you
gotta send me somebody else
i wanna i don't wanna go alone
you know i'm gonna walk through all
these places it's good to have somebody
with you that you're praying together
praying for each other you know and just
it just makes more sense
and so um
i ended up going on facebook and i
remember i was just responding to some
some messages or whatever and i noticed
either he commented on one something
that i did or i don't remember what it
was exactly but somehow i noticed a post
from from levi and i hadn't talked to
him in six years and and we had met at a
rise in 2007 and i mean we were friends
but we weren't i wouldn't say close or
anything like that and and out of
nowhere i just felt impressed that i
should ask him of all people to come
with me to brazil and so i was like hey
man i'm in brazil i'm gonna be here
until june this was i think in december
um that i sent him this message
and um
and i you know i i'm just gonna walk
around and i'm gonna pray for all of
these cities and
and he's like hey you know sounds cool
and you know he asked a few questions
kind of like you know
do you know people in each of these
cities i said no i'm not just one say do
you do you speak the language you know
do you get sponsorship
no you know is there an organization you
know like are you working with churches
you know no
so everything was like no yeah right i
was not quite fuzzy on what we were
actually going yeah so what are you
doing down there so literally like it
was just kind of the only thing that i
had confirmation that i was just gonna
be walking around wow just gonna be
walking around to make myself available
you know like i didn't have any i was
not gonna impose anything upon like hey
i'm coming this is cookie cutter idea
like i did before that's that's how i
arrived in brazil with this this is what
i'm going to impose upon you know this
we should do this and all of a sudden
with that with that gone it was kind of
like
god was just i just want you to show up
and let me open the doors
and so
you know i wasn't expecting a response
from levi i was like man that was some
pretty bad advertisement
but like i don't know like what was your
initial thought like okay this guy's
crazy yeah i i really was quite fuzzy on
what we were actually there for you know
in
probably until i got there and actually
talked to him about it
so
the year
um well 2013 i myself had been in
mexico for like four months
and um
i i went down there and i did some
mission projects with the person i met
down there and went to a school and that
and
i had planned on staying there until
much later than when i actually did
and at some point while i was down in
mexico i felt
god wanted me to come back to the states
for some reason
and
excuse me
uh
i wasn't sure why he brought me back
exactly i i only knew that he did you
know
and after i was back home for a little
bit kind of like you know
just
floating in space you know like what do
i do next that was when alex actually
contacted me
and uh i i told him nothing about that
yeah he of course to this day alex is
saved in my phone as alex from arise
because that was literally all i knew
about him
he was just this guy we weren't even
really friends when we were there
per se
and uh
so when he contacted me
i i thought well that that's interesting
because
i wouldn't have been free really to go
and
i really didn't have i had a little bit
of money left from mexico still
not much
and so i told him well that's that
sounds interesting what i knew of it so
give me a couple days to pray about it i
prayed about it and god impressed me
yeah to to go and
it was funny when it's not an answer i
was expecting yeah
yeah when i i got
to brazil
i kind of you know sat down with alex
like the first day and i was like so
can you just
explain to me
what we're doing oh wow and
you know i i didn't know either you know
i had 800 going down which
was
for the next four months of trains and
planes and tickets and food and hotels
we didn't know what i took a tarp in
case we were going to sleep under
bridges i really didn't know and so
that's faith yeah
that's roughly the same amount that i
had yeah well i asked i i thought you
know maybe he had a little bit more so i
got down there and asked him i was like
so i only have eight hundred dollars
what do you have he's like oh i have 800
which is funny because in the end we
received uh and of course we never
advertised anything we were just anybody
friends we were horrible in fact about
media or anything while we were there we
just post stuff on facebook on rare
occasions we let people in the states
know what we were doing
but yeah so
by the end it was kind of interesting
because we received
in a little over random donations from
people we didn't know have half of them
um a little bit more than eight thousand
dollars and we used
all of it in fact i i had to sell a
camera lens just by my ticket back wow i
didn't even have enough when i got there
to buy my ticket back so neither did he
little did i know we did we had open
tickets we didn't know when we're coming
back so we just bought one ways oh wow
yeah so that was kind of like that that
was the beginning for me getting down
there and finding out
yeah we're just gonna yeah we're just
gonna he told me we're gonna just walk
through the cities
and
pray around stadiums pray through as
many of the streets as we can around the
perimeter of the city you know if it's a
reasonable size
and
i mean i said okay it's amazing because
you think of spiritual warfare like
something crazy is gonna happen and you
know you're on your knees praying and
stuff like this but yeah just simply
just saying hey i want to invite god's
presence to do work something
amazing here but we don't know what i
mean that's neat that you would travel
halfway around the world to do something
like that yeah you know uh that's
actually surprising because that was the
statement that we received
from numerous church members later on
like it's amazing that you would have to
travel halfway around the world to come
teach us what we should be doing in our
own communities right
and not that they weren't active they
had tons of social projects and things
like that outreaches to to people
um but in terms of like engaging in
spiritual warfare they realized
wow we we only know about this
theoretically
and so we were just making ourselves
like we were walking 12 to 15 hours a
day oh wow yeah we were we were racking
up the miles nowhere in brazil were you
sao paulo well i started in sao paulo
but he joined me in salvador so he
started in salvador together okay which
is up in the north we kind of went from
the north all the way through and ended
way south in brazil so okay i ended up
going back to sao paulo but i spent two
months in sao paulo and i spent a little
bit of about a month in salvador and he
was with me in salvador for the last i
think week or two san paulo is one of
their largest cities right i think and
and i remember the first time that i
went there the pastor that picked me up
um he didn't speak much english uh and
and uh he kept blowing through all the
stop lights and i was just like well
maybe that's how they drive down here
you know i don't know
and and so i finally asked him you know
like why do you keep like you don't
you're not they're not paying attention
to the stop lights you know and he was
like oh yeah very dangerous to stop i
was like really
yeah there are certain areas in sao
paulo and other cities where where you
don't want to stop at the stoplight yeah
yeah because that's where a lot of
people i've actually had i've had
certain acquaintances that have been
robbed at stoplights that is a very
common place for that to happen yeah but
but you guys obviously had no major
issues like that at all no well
well we did have lots of well we we did
attempted
stuff yeah we were in
multiple situations i would say that
were
you know two could have been very
dangerous could have been very dangerous
but god always protected us was the
thing
whether we were ignorant of it or
whether we were aware of it yeah so
there's definitely lots of moments where
we kind of recognize things after the
fact
so as you're praying you're kind of like
okay we're what are you praying for like
what are you what are you
sort of engaging with god about that
city well like alex kind of mentioned
earlier basically
when
we first started in the very first city
or when i joined up with him
we decided okay we know we're going to
go around the cities and around stadiums
and all that and
pray for as much of it as we can
um
but should we do anything else because
we didn't really know you know we didn't
have a super clear plan initially so
we said um
we need to pray about whether god wants
us to do
anything direct you know
prayer is the first thing
god is the tip of the spirit right he
goes ahead of us but does he want us to
try to let's say approach the people in
the favelas or approach the prostitutes
on the streets
um
and because
that a part of they were very visible
you go a clock you go after 10 o'clock
at night almost anywhere and you're
gonna find somebody on the corner of the
street selling themselves prostitution
in brazil is legal for adults so it's
it's very open there in a lot of places
yeah it's diff quite different than here
um
so that was the first one right alex is
well i guess the second the first was
walking around the cities
and praying for the cities in the
stadiums
the second would have been
um we were we started praying about at
that first city
do you want us to go and approach people
on the streets
directly or
with church members go and approach you
know prostitutes and stuff
and uh
the third was do you want us to go into
favelas specifically to pray for those
areas because obviously
every dangerous every city that we ended
up going towards we were staying with
the family and you know just god's
provision in that room was amazing
because we didn't we'd always end up in
a city that we didn't know anybody and
there was miraculously a family waiting
for us every time we got to the bus
station or airport or something saying
hey you guys are staying with us
um but every single one of those
families
in conversation about what we're doing
saying well good for you god bless you
but don't walk into favelas and even
after we started walking the favelas
they still told us not to but but we
still knew that
you know later on we figured out that we
should be there and we'll kind of
discuss how we ended up
getting that confirmation
but in just talking with people on the
streets
it was it was funny because i think the
very first day
the very first day that levi and i ended
up just
experimenting like we
you're asking us what are we praying for
and be honest with you
we kind of didn't know
i mean we we knew this to pray for
things in general like lord beyond this
you know this place and whatever but we
honestly didn't know exactly how how do
you do this for 12 hours how is this
like sustainable like do you have to say
things all the time and it was funny
because the very first day i believe was
the very first day that we were walking
some lady within minutes of us like
getting to where we were going to start
walking while we're walking comes up to
us and starts talking to us for half an
hour
she doesn't we don't get a word in
edgewise for 30 plus minutes and we're
just walking with her and she's telling
us her story about her daughter and how
she got fired and it was a nurse at a
hospital and all the troubles that she's
going through and we finally reached a
point where i think we were going to
deviate because we're trying to the
perimeter around the city was like let's
start with that let's just first start
with the perimeter around the city of
salvador
and you know we're going to go in a
different direction we stopped on the
corner and i told her in spanish i
couldn't speak portuguese i told her in
spanish like you know i understood what
you said
but but i i just i don't know how to
speak portuguese
but we'd like to pray for you so she was
the very first person that we prayed
with
in person and it was the very first
moment that we were there on the streets
and she approached us and told
us her story without us even asking all
of a sudden just being present there i
don't know why she shared her life story
with us she never asked us for her names
no not that it was just literally just
30 minutes just she just needed to spill
out all that stuff and we happened to be
the people that she attached to she
obviously spoke english no no no it was
all in portuguese oh wow so how did you
hear well both of us spoke spanish so we
understood
we got bits and pieces and praise the
lord that the way that she spoke
portuguese was not in a way that was
difficult to understand because we made
a lot of connections in in that city
being you know in the north it was for
me at least i just learned spanish the
year before when i was in mexico like
four months worth of spanish you know
that's not that much right and so
getting to salvador where their
accent is there is very
different than way you know yeah and it
was super hard for me to understand most
people her i i got
bits and pieces
you know i would say maybe 50 of what
she was saying
it was right when i got there so it was
quite difficult but alex understood i
had been exposed to hearing portuguese
so after months of being there even
though i didn't speak it i still kind of
was able to you know and so you know and
i spoke to her i used a few words in
portuguese but primarily was like 90
some percent spanish and i was just like
hey you know
we're we're missionaries you know we you
know we feel
you know was she religious at all yes
she was she accepted it she was very
very actually very thankful for that and
she understood why you guys were there
we didn't really give an explanation per
se we're just saying we're just walking
and
i don't even remember if we mentioned we
were praying i remember all the details
we gave her but it was probably very
brief because we didn't really know
ourselves
um but yes that's the way that it kind
of happened and you know god was
revealing it like what do you say for 12
hours a day you know and we realize that
we don't have to say things for 12 hours
a day it's actually a lot more listening
than it is speaking and and there's also
you know something that we started doing
as soon as we got there we started to
also study together
principles
having to do with this
form of ministry maybe you would say
and
god started to sort of open at least my
eyes for sure
up to
what you actually see in scripture
there's a lot of you know things you can
go to but like just as an example
you know abraham
god wanted to give abraham the land
right
and what he told abraham to do in order
to
give him the land was actually to walk
the length and the breadth of it
right so to be there
present to put his foot there and god
would by that act for whatever reason
right basically claim that as his
territory um
you see the same thing with joshua right
got
around the city of jericho they had to
march and after they did that for a
period
god took it and made it his territory
right he took it over broke the walls
down which is an obvious
illustration of spiritual
um
you know like conquest yeah what is it
in
second corinthians 10
it talks about
spiritual strongholds right breaking
them down
um
and so those things exist obviously in
our minds and hearts as individuals they
exist in families and they exist in you
know you can keep expanding yeah to
actual cities and neighborhoods and
you know areas
so we started to see
that principle in scripture of just the
fact of god having a representative
somewhere to invite him was a an
important part not just
the fact that you're talking all day to
god but going there for the the distinct
purpose of being
a representative to invite him to take
it as his territory you know it's
interesting that you're you're making
this comment because i i remember
hearing a testimony from an ex-satanist
that it was his job in new york city to
pray over a certain block of
things and that was his territory and he
was specifically told like you know you
have to give the power to the demons
over this area
and he went in there one day and he had
no power over that area because there
were some evangelists that
come in there and were preaching in the
streets and he couldn't do anything
about it and like he couldn't you know
give the demons power or anything like
this i just thought that was an
interesting perspective i don't actually
maybe i didn't hear that when i heard a
a similar one of another
very similar situation but
um he would go and like curse families
and stuff and there was
one neighborhood where there was a
little group of christians praying for
that neighborhood
and he couldn't touch it you couldn't do
anything there yeah and we've heard
multiple you know examples of that and
and that was some of the things even at
that time uh when you know we would talk
to people why are you walking around the
stadium and doing that well they do the
same thing at rock concerts right right
the satanists want to claim that
territory as their place and so they go
pray to the devil for it yeah and and
you know we we ended up meeting
surprisingly we ended up meeting lots of
ex satanists and and they were
they felt like they were closer to us as
adventists than other types of
adventists because we had experienced
some level of that conflict between good
and evil in a very real sense
and you know when we were thinking of
the verses of ephesians 6 where you know
we were not against flesh and blood but
against principalities and powers the
question is what are those
principalities and powers if it's not
flesh and blood if there's not flesh and
blood then is it visible and if it's
invisible then how do we war against it
and obviously it goes through the you
know the armor and then the weapons of
our warfare are are are all prayer and
and
the sword of the spirit uh which is the
word of god
and so those are the two attack things
and so we were like okay well how do we
utilize these and we you know hadn't had
in mind
of um
kind of bringing down strongholds but
not physical strongholds so we wanted to
be able to become sensitive enough to
the leading of the spirit so that we
could see that which we cannot see
right and that was kind of like we knew
that there was something that we
couldn't touch
but we didn't know how to affect it
and so
what we did is we ended up claiming
god's promises over places right you
know like joshua like wherever you set
the soul of your foot that will i give
you or that i have already given to you
and so we began to claim territory not
just because we felt like there was
something physically inherent physically
like oh this building is mine as much as
it was
basically saying god you have permission
to be here because you have a
representative in the same way that in
the case of job satan came as a
representative and saying i'm coming
from my territory and from walking
walking up and down in it like he's
claiming that it's his because he's
walking
all around it i've put my foot on it
therefore it has the stamp of my
ownership
you know it's kind of like the soul of
his foot is the stamp of ownership and
um
in the same way that god says like you
know the earth is my footstool that's
that's your
that's your authority over it
and um
you know i
i was like lord we need we need to in
many cases be like job that you can say
to satan listen satan i get your claim
but have you considered the fact that
i've got people that are within your
territory and they're walking that same
place they're putting the same foot the
same place you've got your foot
and so you cannot say that it's
completely yours because i respect i get
you don't i get you don't but but i
respect choice and therefore if people
are asking me
to be there when they are themselves
there therefore i have the right by by
you know rules of engagements to
intervene
because someone is present and they're
asking me to be there and that's a good
important window like how much we need
to actually do that all the time not
only just you know our schools and
and i mean physical places that are
around here like lord i'm your
representative here used this as a tool
to win people into your kingdom you know
and yeah i mean isn't that why we're
called the temple of the holy spirit
because wherever there's a temple
wherever there's a temple god can be
there right so it's just we're in
essence uh god's passports to areas
um
to areas that that that haven't chosen
him
but by way of our representation now
have the option to do so and that's
actually one of the things that that was
probably the most impactful in our
discoveries especially in entering to
the favela yeah when you think about in
the old testament the tabernacle was
where god
god's presence dwelt inside the
tabernacle so wherever it traveled
around
is where god's presence
would dwell essentially right
or whether the the pillar would follow
and so if you think about the new
testament version of that which is his
people
if you want to god go into a place
yes we have you know we can pray from
the united states for brazil
but if we really are the the temple of
god why not
take the tabernacle into brazil right so
that
so so the pillar will follow right right
or go ahead maybe it's a better way and
then a lot of people will ask the
question why can't you just tell the
people in brazil to pray well
everybody knows to pray
but but we were approaching it
in a very different way not because we
knew exactly like i said what we're
doing but because we felt like there was
something that god was trying to reveal
to us something that he was trying to
teach us um
and and yeah you know
many days were uneventful
they were uneventful but but we had
enough powerful experiences to kind of
really stand out and be like man that's
that's a unique once in a lifetime type
of thing yeah and i'm sure the devil
discourages you during those times too
like see what you're doing here is not
effective sure sure you know
but
talk about some of those examples of
things that really you saw the hand of
god and was
a reason for you to say this is why
we're here the confirmations was the
great was was once you know where to go
you feel confident right it's kind of
like god's leading the way he's given
you the go-ahead he's like i appreciate
your heart i'm with you in this continue
like a lot of us we want to know what
god's will is and in many ways god has
revealed us his will
he makes it pretty clear like you see
people in need don't turn away from it
you know but but run to those in need
sacrifice yourself for the sake of
others and so we knew that we were
obeying the the clear commandment but we
just wanted confirmation that god was
going to
keep us in that so we weren't going
presumptuously like yes we have the
heart to do it but but we also don't
know how to do it
and so so we won't
we're going to try but we don't want to
engage ourselves i don't know i don't
want to say too deeply but but in in an
ineffective manner if if we're just
going to do it of our own accord right
that's why i think like when you read
the story of jonathan and his armor
bearer i think it's neat that he he's
like okay god
if they tell us to come over there we
know that exactly exactly and if they
don't so i think god is used to us
you know allowing that test to know that
hey is this your will god is this what
you want for me and if it is give me
that sign and i'll react to that you
know i mean jonathan already had the
burden to relieve the pressure from his
people they were running away they were
hiding in caves they're kind of like
okay lord we know that you can bring
victory out of this we want to be the
instruments through which you bring
victory
let us know that that you're going to do
that right now and that was kind of what
we're already bought our tickets we
bought one-way tickets we're here we we
know what's going on we want to do
something about it and we know that
that's what you want you want to reach
to these to these people
and there doesn't seem to be anybody
else doing it but we still want
say yes i'm with you and so it was just
we were going to do it but we wanted to
know that we were doing it with him and
not that's right not of our own i think
there's nothing wrong with asking god
confirmation show me that that we are
doing something that you want us to do
right you know i think i think god wants
us to interact with him like that he
wants to be our god he wants to to
reveal his will to us he's waiting for
us to abide in his will so yeah at times
god
has volunteered confirmations like to
moses right most didn't ask but god
showed him
three signs you know that he was going
to be with him and other times like you
know gideon asked and he he got it
for sure so we we ended up uh in his
which was the second city that we were
in after salvador
and so we just in salvador all we ended
up doing was the first thing just
walking around completely around the
city uh praying for the different places
dedicating the place we we walked around
the stadium seven times we kind of said
we're let's walk around the stadium
seven times we had heard that they walk
around three times those that dedicated
to satan we're like wow whatever we just
do seven times because that's a good
number now we didn't have any basis per
se for this so we we initially kind of
like well joshua walked around seven
times and then we realized no it was
actually 13 times he walked six around
one time for six days in the seventh day
he walked around seven times like oh
whatever we we did it wrong but we still
were there we were learning right we god
god i don't think was like well you know
you should have walked an extra six
times otherwise i'm not gonna be short
no no but it's just it's just like you
know it was
it was god being patient with us
and and we didn't have it all figured
out
and and we were willing to be corrected
and i think that was the important part
is that we were willing to say you know
what there's a better way we can do this
each each city let's improve but i think
that's that's that's a good space to be
in
i think when we go into it confidently
sometimes where we're like we got this
all figured out and we're just gonna do
x y and z and we've got this plan
it's like god's like okay well you got
it all figured out right i think he
wants us in that space to say look i
don't know what i'm doing here and lord
just show the way and he's like now i
can work with you oh it looks impossible
now i can now i can show you who's the
captain am i the captain or is god the
captain am i am i willing to listen to
directions or am i going to basically
say god this is the way that i'm doing
it you know
um
but you know we we we ended up in hasife
and we were looking for that direction
and we we we felt compelled to go into
favelas and once again we were told both
by the family in salvador and by the
family we were staying with in his ife
it's not a good idea but there was this
guy at this particular church that we
were at
where the family we were with attended
and he is his name was stephen and he
really wanted to reach out to
um
to to people in in the favelas uh that
was right across from the church
literally just across the street was the
alley that was leading into this favela
and the church had never ministered in
that favela
and he was like he was frustrated you
know he's like oh i'm gonna do something
and so he started a copperware class
which is kind of like a dance martial
art that's prominent in in brazil
to bring kids from the favela
you know on onto the church grounds and
and
you know he did that and
we were talking to him and
you know you could tell that he wanted
to do something was a little bitter to
the church wouldn't help him and
we're here we're here
and so one time after the cop work class
ended i think like eight or nine o'clock
at night it was the last day also that
we were gonna be in that city yeah
that's why that's why we were kind of
interested oh yeah that's right that's
right it was it was we were kind of like
man we've been here all this time we've
already attended a few classes of his
already with you know like hey man we're
going to leave and so yeah that might
have been the motivation well yeah
because normally it's a bad idea to go
into a favela it's a worse idea if
you're americans going in and it's even
worse if you're americans going in at
night and it was already at night and so
but
we said like
we prayed
you know
yeah if god wants to go in we're going
to go in so and because it was our last
night we were taking pictures of his
class so we were filming and taking
pictures of his class and so we had a
camera with us so it's even worse to
walk in with a dslr right but that was
our last chance in that sense i bring
that up that's why we went in at night
because they basically will
target you if they think you're gonna
you know video them huh yeah well it can
be yeah like what's this guy doing here
you know kind of it's it's a bit
suspicious
if they're doing something shady right
um but we we didn't have any
expectations we we we said either we're
ignorant americans or we're faithful we
weren't sure which ones but we're going
to go
and so we you know
i i turned to to leave and i was like
hey you know i feel like we should walk
into this favela i was like how do you
feel about it and uh he was like
what was your response i was going to
say sure yeah are you married at this
time no none of us were none of us were
yeah so
we're both single
so yeah
um so
he he's he felt fine i felt fine stephen
was a bit
trepidatious that's even a word
um and we just started walking towards
this alley and there was a guy on the
corner and he was he's like looking at
these guys approaching and he's walks
towards us and he's like whoa whoa where
are you guys going he says well we're
thinking of walking in that vlc
you're not from this favela i was like
oh i know
and you know stephen says you know i
attend this church across the street and
these guys are missionaries and you know
we were kind of you know
they're praying they're praying for the
city and they want to know if they can
pray for your community and and uh if
there's anything that we can do to you
know to minister to you guys if there's
any needs and he's like
oh sounds good yeah i think we'd love to
have you but but i got it i got to check
with the big boss
and so my first thought is oh man
big boss who's that was that gonna be
like is that a drug dealer is that a
trafficker is that some kind of like you
know organized crime mob boss kind of
thing you know that's kind of what i'm
picturing in my head
he actually takes us to the high priest
of contemplate contemplate is kind of
like a black magic religion kind of like
sun teddy it's a combination of like
voodoo and catholicism so they'll have
pictures of saints but they'll have
idols and they'll have they'll do they
actually do witchcraft and and we don't
have a whole lot of time to discuss just
the amount of times that we encountered
witchcraft not just in the favelas but
just
as a concept throughout and the power of
curses
whether you believe them or not it the
the way that they've changed the
dynamics of the way that people live and
the stories of how it's affected them
and
and um you know all of these these
things sacrifices of animals and and
whatnot that
and
it'll probably a little bit of that will
come into play a little bit later
but we go to this guy this high priest
of black magic his house
and he
he's asking us what we're doing there
and so we say we tell them what we're
doing
and he said something that probably
helped shape tremendous amounts of our
view from that point
and our prayer ministry gave
confirmation to our prayer ministry he
said
you know all of us grow up
knowing that spiritual warfare is real
we see the darkness
all the time every day
but
and we know that church across the
street
but no one has ever come
to represent the other side to us
if we had known something else
maybe we would have chosen something
else
but we only live in accordance with what
we know
and you guys are the first to come to us
to
reveal to us what that other side might
be
you have full access to my entire
community you can go wherever you want
the guy who met you at the door knows
everybody he'll be your guide he'll take
you everywhere you want to go oh wow you
have
my permission and my protection in this
entire favela wow talk to whoever you
want take whatever pictures and video
you want
it's it's all open to you and so he's
involved in sort of dark spiritualism
yeah he would
um but he was totally yeah totally open
to it yeah i mean that kind of gives you
a little window into you know like
we're all in this battle together too
right i mean you know not to just judge
somebody off of their external you know
yeah and in fact when we were done
talking with him we prayed
uh for him
wow he accepted prayer yeah yeah and uh
come to find out later as we talked to
the churches there and stuff their view
of the people in those communities was
actually the hindrance it wasn't the
people themselves
um they were really open yeah yeah
they're dominant
oh yeah yeah what are the predominant
view of of of most people whether it be
high priests of contemplate or or mob
bosses or prostitutes or traffickers is
that they're beyond hope right they're
people that there's
but there's a lot of circumstances that
put people in those situations you know
whether you grew up in poverty and you
know it's a dog-eat-dog world and you
fend for whatever you can to survive and
they end up in that place but yeah
there's some
you know part of their heart that's not
fully given over to to the evil one so
um yeah i mean we're all in need of
saving
our experiences were predominantly that
they were put in situations where they
had no other choices not that it was
what they
chose their desire right it was not
hey this is how i wish to live my life
it was just this is i've got no better
option currently
but you know one of the
one of the things as we were traveling
through there
was how how quick man is to close the
door that god has opened
is as i was filming you know what we
were going through taking pictures
people were just showing up and
you know putting away their bottles of
glue they were sniffing glue from
bottles and people put away their their
their marijuana and whatever else they
were doing
um you know everybody became holy and
once once we didn't ask them we didn't
we didn't say anything it was just i
don't know just the
the atmosphere changed
um and then at one point in time like i
was trying to film
you know levi and our guide
walking down the street by this time
there was a large group it was like 20
some people walking
and um
just people started gathering around us
and i was like i gotta film this and it
was it was a it was a pretty shoddy
camera and there's there's not a lot of
lights it's not like
the street lights are not like official
street lights they're like bulbs hanging
from like some dangling wire from some
makeshift telephone pole that somebody
erected to put 500 wires to illegally
tap into you know like electricity and
all that kinds of stuff so so this is
this is you know
right nothing is to code and like it's
very interspersed so there's no good
lighting and we don't have a great
camera to begin with
and uh so you know i'm trying to like
hold it steady and try to get things in
focus manually and i'm you know i'm
shooting with a 1.8 wide open and i'm
like trying to make it happen
and uh i noticed this guy creeping up on
me because like by this time i'm trying
to figure this out they had already
walked a bit of distance away and they
were kind of almost out of earshot
and i noticed this guy coming up behind
me and i'm like what is what's this guy
doing like i noticed like he was
he was eyeing he was eyeing me like i
could just feel like his you know like
this guy probably wants my camera he's
probably waiting for that group to
disappear and he's gonna like nab and
have the camera and uh i'm like i got
this man just let him touch me see what
happens
i'm i'ma pop this guy
and uh you know i i had trained in
martial arts i felt confident you know
all of a sudden you know me
lifting up and
um immediately the guy that our guy he
turns around just out of nowhere he's
talking with levi he's surrounded by a
group of you know 20-some people like
they're they're almost out of sight
around the corner he turns around he
like puts his hand out and he says no
get away from him he's with me
he just yells it on the top like he had
eyes at the back of his head yeah
and this guy like just
splits
just runs i don't even get to see his
face
you know and all of a sudden i'm like
man
i could have ruined it like he was this
opportunity that opened god just you
know you could have access to my entire
community what would have happened even
if justified
even if justified well that guy tried to
rob me and i and i you know i busted his
lip or something like
that would have closed everything
and i was like i get it okay each step
god is teaching me like i brought you
here i'm gonna protect you take care of
you just
just trust me trust me in the process
i don't don't don't try to take back
that which i'm giving you right just
just let me handle it
uh you just you're along for the ride
and so that's that's one of the things
that we were learning is just listening
listening and not imposing
wow i mean i've always wanted to go in
the favelas i've been down there a
number of times and i've never actually
never really been into one because they
all say the same thing you know don't go
in there it's like really super
dangerous and stuff
but yeah that's that's that's really
interesting that you guys have this
experience i mean that really goes to
show like uh you know
if you allow god to lead you i mean he
could put you in some crazy situations
that that
everyone else would be like nah sorry
that's just hopeless cause
but here you get an opportunity to go in
there you know you have no idea what
kind of seeds
you guys left there and we don't yeah
that's the thing is you know
we don't always get responses to that
and sometimes we do and we had tons of
responses of what we heard that happened
after we were already gone
we got calls from people and stuff like
that saying this happened after you left
and whatever you don't get that all the
time but but there it happened enough
times where we were like okay well
something something did matter it didn't
matter right something happens this is
sort of like the the beginning of seeing
god
in all of it you know like um one of the
other
if we want to call them projects that we
mentioned that we had been praying about
was also
should we approach people on the streets
directly you know personally or take
maybe church members out and
try to
talk to pray with even the prostitutes
out in the streets
yeah i had a little bit of initial
hesitation with that one but that's why
we needed like
confirmation yeah well that was actually
so
going in this first favela god really
showed us that was like his confirmation
he opened the doors wide open
and
showed us not only the
the people are receptive but also
his protection and
you know
giving us even somebody to to take us
through and all that
um
it's pretty clear on on that one but
then on
the
third
you know thing that we were praying
about approaching people directly like
prostitutes directly on the streets
um it was another really interesting
experience we had with that right up
front too was that the same city or was
it the next yeah
so so yeah in the same city
we were one day
driving with one of the church members
who was just kind of taking us
around some different places that day
and
he was also a person who
would spend time praying for people like
in his normal daily life
and
he felt he felt inspired by what we were
doing he says i'm going to make it a
habit to find five people to pray with
every day
so he was driving with us and he stopped
to get some gas he's like to the gas
attendant because in brazil they fill up
your tank you don't fill up your own
tank like can i pray for you she's like
okay and then we stopped at a little
shack to get like a watermelon or
something and he's like can i pray for
you and so so he he's like i'm gonna do
what you guys are doing and he found his
own way to do it because that's what
that wasn't what we were doing but but
but he he's like this is the way that i
feel that i should do it and we were
like meanwhile he's an inspiration to us
you know like i wish i could speak
portuguese yeah you know i wish i could
pray with people but yeah so while we
were out driving with him though we saw
as we were on the highway we saw up you
know a little ways up on um there was an
overpass
a bridge
and
there was a lady under the bridge there
and he told us he said see the lady up
there that's a prostitute and it was
weird because it was right in the middle
of the day it was like noon or one
probably very very unusual and he said
do you guys want to stop and
pray for her you know
and we had to think about it for a
second because it was three guys
normally
it's not the best appearance yeah right
but at least it was in the middle of the
day so
there's cars passing we were gonna stay
in the car so we're just like okay i
think it'll be fine yeah so so
we said well sure let's we'll stop and
see if we can pray for her so
he pulled over there by the you know in
front of the bridge
and she kind of
she was you could tell she was hesitant
at first
um she kind of walked over to one side
of the van first and was kind of
pretending like you know she didn't
notice we were there or whatever
and then after a couple you know
moments they were just kind of waiting
seeing what she was going to do she came
around to the
driver's side window
and he was driving of course so he
rolled the window down she said do you
guys want a program that's what they
call it there
well she's like what do you want and
then he's like well i'm here with two
americans and the moment she heard two
americans she's like oh do they wanna
are they here for a program which
program is basically yeah
so
um he explained to her no they're not
actually here for that they're
missionaries they're here
to pray for our you know cities and for
people and
we just want to know if there's anything
we can pray for for you wow and as soon
as he said that it was a really
interesting thing her whole countenance
really changed like she she switched off
from the process performance to this is
me she became yeah the the mother and
the person you know the mother of her
children she started talking to us
like immediately it just flipped and she
said actually
yes i believe in prayer i believe in god
and i pray too
and she was like
the only reason i'm out here is because
i have two kids i don't have a husband
i don't have work and i don't know what
else to do i have nothing else and i
have to provide for my kids i don't know
what else to do i'm desperate she had no
education no training nothing but get
this she she told us
so she's going through this whole thing
and kind of explaining to us why she was
there and she said i don't know if you
guys know
who the adventists are
but i'm actually studying to become
baptized in the adventist church oh wow
and just so happens you know where we
told her yeah we know who who the
adventists are yeah
and wow but she was saying that she she
she was praying for god to give her a
way out because she knew that she
couldn't be baptized until she was out
of this life yeah and she felt kind of
like stuck between a rock and a heart
and people at the church didn't know
either she said she said i don't know
what to do because i i want to follow
god i want to be baptized but i'm in
between a rock and a hard place you know
the guy that we were with though it just
so happened that he
his wife was a social worker and so he
got connected with her and got his wife
connected to find her work and you know
help her out of that situation
but that was the first person that we
stopped to directly approach
on the street the first prostitute
and the very first prostitute we
approached was she was studying to be
come an adventist that's crazy and she
wanted out of that life she was waiting
for somebody she was she was praying
she's like god send me somebody to take
me out of this life and we were like god
send us a sign that we should be
reaching out to people in this life yeah
and so it was it was it was a double it
was just a double blessing and her name
was hosanna i love it was just
orchestrating this beautiful like like i
imagine when he went and spoke with the
woman of the well yeah that only wasn't
just for the woman at the well right
that was for his disciples to see that
look i'm the type of god that would go
out of my way just to meet that person
right there to a foreign country you
don't speak the language why are we here
god what are we doing here you know like
that's the attitude that i'm imagining
that the disciples had like they didn't
want to be there and then all of a
sudden it's like why is he talking to
this woman you know what's he doing
there
and and and so amazing that look at how
this woman responded she didn't need a
sign she didn't need a miracle she
immediately went out what'd she do she
started telling everybody about what an
amazing god he was so imagine that kind
of an experience too is it's like you
know we are all caught up in this life
of sin and and for whatever reason we've
gotten deceived and and put in certain
circumstances and things that that you
know it's easy for us to judge that
person and be like well she chose all
those wrong choices and everything but
we don't know at what level god has and
that's the thing in your heart in in the
same way that that the disciples would
have looked at the samaritan woman and
going in the middle of the day like oh
that's that's okay like she's obviously
trying to avoid people like even amongst
the people that we consider low she's
even lower than them you know there's a
lot of things that you know and and and
when we look at at this particular
situation it wasn't like we had to
convince her of anything
she was already wanting to be bad we
never gave her a bible study
right we never we never said hey we're
adventists it was it was none of that it
was
i want to reveal to you
right that i'm already working in the
lives of people in ways that you cannot
imagine i just need you to be there for
when they're ripe for the picking
that's so i do the work
you show up right right so it's
that was the way really though the whole
time
the way that it felt the entire time we
were there was that we were running
always a step behind where god was
and so this is literally the tip of the
iceberg this is like the first two
cities of twelve so
um
in fact with this story just to to
follow this up really quick
in conjunction with praying should we
approach you know people on the streets
we were also asking should we get the
churches to to do the same thing
and it it just so happened that
we met her in this second city that we
were in
and shortly after we went to the third
city
and when we got there
it was during
carnival yeah in brazil which is crazy
so the adventist church is what they do
during that time
yeah they go basically like retreat
pathfinder camp house yeah into the
the woods you know whatever to get the
especially for the youth to get the
youth out of this so we got dragged to
this youth retreat
kicking and screaming because we were
like no we need to be there when the
worst things are happening they're like
no you don't need to be there during
carnival and we didn't have an idea like
yours once again but uh but yeah
carnival that's like an annual festival
they have yeah it's uh like the word
it's very sensual so people they
literally like go down the streets
wearing almost nothing and but we didn't
know that it was more than just
feathers and you know
bikinis and stuff like that that there's
actually people doing drugs having sex
in the streets doing some very like
things that you were like whoa what is
what is going on here we found that out
later and it's actually very dangerous
too
a lot of people get drugged and raped
and things like that during that time
and so it's just
it's it's it's chaotic there's people
drinking like days non-stop like two
three days and just
all night like noise and it's it's you
know
there's this kind of once again a
romanticization of of like oh it's
pretty and look at the pageantry and all
that kinds of stuff but that's like on
one road right everything outside of
that one road where the pageant is is is
chaos yeah so so we ended up
out at some like pathfinder camp where
you pretty much
um a bunch of young people at the
beginning of that you know experience in
that city
and the first night it was the first
night right that we got there or was it
the second i think it was the next day
so
some of the the youth there found out
that we were from the states and stuff
people just ask you you know just off
the cuff whatever what are you doing
here why'd you come to brazil we were
speaking english and so it didn't take
long to notice you know and uh so we
told them while we're here
praying for the cities we're
missionaries i guess
and uh
we're doing some
you know outreach to
trafficking victims and prostitutes and
stuff and in fact alex
took like what hour couple hours two to
three hours to just explaining about all
that's going on especially leading up to
the world cup and i was surprised there
were 40 people that sat in because
during that time they ended up asking
somebody ended up asking us well can you
just sort of
explain to the group what you're here
for so he did that for a couple of hours
by this time
we were getting
more portuguese so
at the end of that
talk or you know
sharing that with them
a group of what fifteen to twenty maybe
thirteen and fifteen some of that young
people they came up and said
what you've just described because he
went through like you know what he had
done in um atlanta atlanta of going out
and giving the a little you know note
and a rose
to the ladies on the street
as an outreach it was called princess
knight
that was part of what he explained
um
and they said
it's it's really not a coincidence that
you guys are here right now because this
group
basically a youth group
all the the youth there had been feeling
impressed for like the past three weeks
or month
about going out and reaching out to
prostitutes on the streets and they told
us they're like we've all felt we need
to do this
just recently but we have no idea what
to do
and just now as we've been for about the
past two weeks we've been praying about
it together for god to show us what to
do and here you are yeah tell us what to
do and we'll go do it because what
you're describing is is exactly what
we've been feeling we need to to do so
literally the the city before god showed
us yes
go out and approach them and the very
next city that we landed in he had the
group waiting for us to go out and do
that you know and yeah and we were being
begged to go to that retreat and there's
the reason why it was just god was
trying to get us to where we needed to
be and we were already had our own ideas
now we need to do this and god god was
like no yeah so let me show you let me
show you so it's just it just
reveals that
you can't plan it any better than he
does that's right
you just can't i think god is waiting
for us to have an open heart and when we
have an open heart he's able to work and
orchestrate
mighty things through us um but it's
like when we go into any situation where
we're like okay we've got this all
figured out and you know it's like god's
like okay well apparently you're driving
you know so i'm he can bless that kind
of situation but i've heard time and
time again this type of situation my
brother has a ministry that they do that
they do those same sort of things they
just got back from ukraine and i was
like who did you know in ukraine didn't
know anyone we just went over there we
started handing out glow tracks and and
things and all of a sudden they have
these just uh amazing stories that that
came through that and it's like they had
zero plan
most people would look at that and be
like you're crazy you know what i'm
responsible yeah to even like spend the
money to go over there and and do that
and you know they're running around and
they're like there's a lot of churches
around there
that weren't doing anything and so they
were like you know hey god sent us from
the united states to come over here to
hand information out you know and they
inspired some of the church members so i
mean you know maybe god
needs us as well to inspire each other
yeah maybe sometimes you know being a
fish out of your own
pond is is the best way for us to to you
know feel uncomfortable and un
unworthy and god's like now i can use
you here you go
i'm sure you have more on the next
episode and
we hope you guys were blessed by this
you know if there's any time that you
ever feel
like you don't know why you're there you
don't know what's going on and you just
feel impressed that god has put you in
that situation in that time
just like alex and
levi have shared here that's sometimes
the best place to be god can use you
mightily in those situations if you just
open your heart to him and so you know
prayer is an amazing tool that many of
us don't use to the extent that we
should be using it
and uh i guarantee you if you stu if you
open your heart and you open your mind
to praying and letting god orchestrate
your life um you will you will be amazed
at what happened so we hope you guys
were blessed by today's episode check
out the episode before which these guys
talked about their experience of getting
involved in
anti-human trafficking i think i said
that right um and not necessarily human
trafficking but the work against the
human traffickers and um you guys will
you guys will be shocked but much of
that kind of stuff goes on here on our
u.s soil and uh you know god's looking
for soldiers in this area as well so we
uh we hope that you guys were blessed by
today's episode and we can't wait to
hear more of this story so stay tuned
and uh thanks for stopping by see ya
[Music]
so
[Applause]
[Music]
you